magister went ashore accompanied by the
governor of fiji she reinvented monarchy
and took it to the world from young
queen to global megastar she was
incredibly popular i mean she was like
this
multi-media star the lifetime of travels
would circle the planet 40 times over
as the world changed beyond recognition
queen elizabeth remained constant
confidant and confessor to presidents
and prime ministers
what's quite extraordinary is the love
and affection they had for her
and champion of a commonwealth of
nations and it's two and a half billion
people
the ability to come to your level and
tell you that you're doing a good work
meant almost everything to me
as queen of canada for nearly six
decades
my pride in this country remains
undimmed
we've become used to seeing the queen on
the world stage but it was a role she
envisaged even before being crowned i
declare before you all
that my whole life
whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service
and to the service of our great imperial
family to which we all belong
it was a promise she would honor from
the very beginning barely six months
after her coronation embarking on a tour
of the commonwealth
[Music]
the royal couple drew enormous crowds
welcome was the word formed by some of
the 17 000 children on melbourne cricket
ground there was no doubt they met it
it was clear that this was going to be a
very different kind of monarch
the queen when she came to the throne
she was very young but she had very
clear ideas of how she wanted to shape
her role and definitively travel and
international collaboration and building
an international community and
particularly the commonwealth was so
important to her the queen and prince
philip toured the commonwealth for six
months taking in its vast size and
diversity
by the end the young queen was already
becoming a global icon
it was lower broadway that supplied the
dictate snowstorm a status cemented a
few years later when she took new york
by storm
americans came out in their thousands
inside the great assembly hall 2 500
delegates and their wives rose to greet
the queen
when the queen went on her visits in the
early days no one had any idea she'd be
so popular they had no idea there'd be
thousands of people the advisors were
really quite surprised by the level of
popularity the level of fascination
level of the fact that everyone seemed
to be out there on the street who wants
to see a glimpse of the queen and she
was incredibly popular i mean she was
like this
multi-media star she was like the
ultimate celebrity bigger than a
hollywood celebrity
on the maintenance of understanding
between us
the future of the free world depends
she was already mastering the arts of
soft power her personal chemistry with
leader after leader would prove one of
her most effective assets
i saw her with leaders like president
yeltsin and sort of again the level of
conversation and confidence and
ability to to observe your discretions
and and secrets
very high and i think you know
got on well because he respected the
queen of having
some enduring qualities that are not
related to politics or the stage of
george politically
very few could claim to be on an equal
footing with the queen
nelson mandela was one i mean she could
speak very frankly with him because he
was a prince in his own tribe so in that
sense he had an easy way
with the queen he's the only head of
state i've ever had call the queen
elizabeth
at home the queen hosted world leaders
some of them less savoury than others
but treated them all with the same
decorum and royal welcome
her role was far from just ceremonial
she had a diplomatic importance with a
global reach and depth politicians could
only dream of
we in britain have often underestimated
the immense impact that the queen had on
the whole of the world
with america she had met 14
u.s presidents nobody in the world not
even in america has met 14 presidents
and then taken a place like ireland she
was pivotal in bringing about that
reproduction
uh between britain and ireland in 2011
so a hugely understated but very
significant influence globally the
monarchy continues the monarchy
will always continue that's what it's
designed to do but will anybody coming
in now
have that same
uh clout that same uh footprint on world
history obviously not the queen
driving the queen's ambition above all
was a passion for the commonwealth to
see something good rise out of the end
of empire secretary general says the
queen played a unique role for all of
its leaders
you could tell her anything
and she'd never talk about it
and she had the wisdom
and the generosity to listen
and then to give really sage
quiet advice and so
i think if you had the privilege as a
number of us have of seeing her
interact with them
what's quite extraordinary is the love
and affection they had for her i commend
the queen's young leaders of 2018.
but the queen's love for people extended
far beyond leaders and politicians she
had a passion for the youth of the
commonwealth
like derek omari who set up a charity
for disabled children in ghana age 19
singled out by her majesty for the
queen's youth leader awards
it was it was a day that
nobody ever thought about i knowing
where i grew up never ever thought of in
my life that i even leave ghana to the
uk and then come all the way to the
backyard palace and be on it
and and one of the things that really
left that that that has gotten stuck
with me
was
the chance to meet her in person
have a conversation with her
humanness and the ability to come to
your level and tell you that you're
doing a good work
keep doing it
keep going on and we are proud of you
meant almost everything to you
for rihanna patterson recognised for
setting up a dementia charity the queen
was a personal inspiration she was a
young person taking on this leadership
role and she had to kind of
find herself in it quite quickly you
know there was a lot of formalities a
lot of rules a lot to take in and it was
something that was quite sudden
so i think she is relatable in that
regard like taking on a stunts at a
young age
the woman who took on so much in her 20s
will go on inspiring so many other young
people like her for decades and carry on
travelling for as long as her health
would let her
the queen transformed the monarchy
turning it into a globe-shotting
multimedia phenomenon years ahead of her
time letting britain punch above its
weight in the world and leading a
commonwealth of nations
a death leaves a void and she has
mourned by hundreds of millions far
beyond these shores
dominic waghorn sky news